it's a cnbc story own everything but
bubble assets tech and crypto recommends
institutional investor hall of famer
rich bernstein which we know who he is
he has got a big reputation he's he's a
winner he's done well for himself on one
side he says we have all that i would
call the bubble assets tech innovation
disruption cryptocurrencies
this is rich bernstein who ran strategy
at merrill lynch on the other side of
this seesaw you have literally
everything else in the world i think if
you're looking at 2022 into 2023 you
want to be in the everything else in the
world side of that seesaw his number one
pick is energy a group he listed as a
top play coming into 2021 earlier this
year bernstein called oil
the most ignored bull market bernstein
also sees cryptocurrency as a major
problem last june he warned the rush to
own bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
was becoming dangerously parabolic
cryptos are the biggest financial bubble
ever in the history this is just a
monster one do you agree with them
well it depends on the timing like when
he says so for example if bitcoin goes
from 47 000 to
000 and then crashes is he right well i
guess he is but
kathy wood takes the opposite right she
says we're not in a bubble right now of
arc investing and um so it all it all
comes perspective i don't think we've
seen the parabolic run on bitcoin that
he's describing and i certainly don't
think it's the biggest bubble ever do i
think everything is in a bubble when you
pump this much liquidity into the
economy then sure you're going to create
bubbles and so it's all a matter of
perspective do i think that there's
going to be some type of crash
um
some point next year yes you know is
that the later half is that the first
half the first quarter i don't know i
wish i did
um but um
i think he's right that we're we're
headed for a major correction i just
don't know when you know what i mean you
know we talk about the tech bubble was
tech really a bubble i mean
was it a bubble because look at what
look at what apple is 99 it was what i'm
saying look at what happens oh yeah yeah
look at what microsoft is there there's
a difference between a bubble and
disruptive
technology there's a difference between
a bubble and changing industries you
know like if somebody was like back in
the day you know a car
costs five hundred dollars a ford model
t well i can get a horse for twenty five
dollars i'm never spending five hundred
dollars for a car that's an as9 you know
and then you know there's a million
dollar cars now right that drives him
when he gets bored on the weekends like
is that a bubble was is that parabolic
or is it changing technology like
i think you you said it best it's a
matter of perspective of time like if
ripple if you guys settle if you guys
win this case and it goes up to a dollar
fifty what's crazy is people will be
like
it's just a two hundred it's a two
hundred percent like like that's not
even good at crypto anymore it's like
why well ten times twenty yeah if it's
not if it's not nine thousand x it's not
worth my time like it's it's so in that
aspect of it there's a speculation
bubble but i don't think i mean if
you're
oil man i mean with exxon with the
activists that they have like yeah look
always be in energy always be in things
that people use it's not sexy you know
but you got to be in things that people
use but you think crypto is going away
to me bubble means it's going away
yeah is real estate is real estate a
bubble right now
i think real estate is a mathematical
formula you know meaning like if
interest rates go up and real estate's
going to take a hit you know goldman
sachs is predicting rates are going to
go up seven times in 2022. wow that's a
lot of times when goldman says seven
times uh rates there's no way oh listen
i
in a midterm election year you think
that look at look at the political
pressure that he's dealing with you
think that there did you hear what biden
said yesterday says republicans i just
want to tell you it's going to be a bad
midterm election for you did you hear
him say that yeah okay i think they're
getting wrecked
they're getting wrecked well the number
is 63 i think it's 61 or 63 the record
held by the most seats to flip and the
person that owns the record is his
former boss barack obama so we're going
to see whether he's going to flip that
many like he's going to lose that many
seeds well i i hope they lose the seats
because i want to see gary ginsler and
committee answering some questions it'd
be interesting to see that taking place
how can people help put pressure pla
what can people do that are listening to
this help put public pressure on them so
that this investigation happens if they
go to crypto uh
www.crypto.us cryptolaw.us if they go to
that there's a tab in the law.us yes if
they go to that there's a tab connect to
congress and that goes to your senators
and your congress representatives and
you can you could put on pressure simply
say you want an investigation into this
you want the sec to come answer
questions under oath these guys are
skating it you know their investigation
into specifically investigation into the
sec and the filing of this case and the
way it went down and the conflicts of
interest conflicts and here's the thing
only good can come from an independent
investigation because when the let's say
pat gerard let's say that there was no
actual crime but when the appearance of
impropriety rises to the level that it
destroys public conflict credibility
right then if you do an investigation
and it's fair and it's independent you
come back and say no crime was committed
no quit pro quo you know uh but they
could have done disclosures done this
better fine if if there is a crime
committed if there was a quid pro quo
then justice is done what was the tweet
that you said yesterday you had a tweet
yesterday hey let's let's uh let the
truth hey let the truth fall where it
may
just a matter of time well john i'm glad
we were able to make this work
absolutely thank you so much we
never do podcasts on wednesday but we
did it because we wanted to have a sit
down we cannot believe it i hope the
audience has enjoyed it
and uh learned just as much as we have
uh folks if you don't follow john on
twitter he posts stuff there regularly
and he's very active i suggest you go
follow him on twitter what's your handle
on twitter by the way johnnydeaton1 john
e
deaton
one yeah okay john eden one on twitter
you can find them there as well as we
put the link there crypto law dot us
crypto law that us to follow what's gone
on over here john appreciate you for
coming out so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you